Yeah,
I want to return briefly to this and
Ganja because there may be some confusion
caused by disillusionment.
The English word used to translate
the term which is an approximation.
Uh, as, uh, all translations are,
uh, busy illusion meant, uh,
can mean in English disenchantment and
disappointment words that have a very
negative connotation,
whereas this in Ganja does not
quite have that connotation.
Uh,
at worse it could mean resignation.
Meaning I was resigned to find out that
such and such a person was not as good
as I thought him or her to be.
Uh,
remember the quote from Otis Green that I,
uh,
read you in which the same
ganja was a thought of us are,
uh,
the sumo boom boom or the ultimate
good desired by the storage wise man,
baroque disingenuous.
It's,
it's a positive condition at which the
individual arrives after having shared
the scales from his eyes, remember, uh,
and learned of the deceitfulness
of appearances of the
mystifying allure of all
that he has taken as being very valuable.
Everything that shines is not gold,
is what the individual learns.
Having gone through the process of in
Ganja that is deceit and this and Ganja to
put it in, in the simplest of terms. Uh,
what I suggested more over is that the
plot of the Quixote and that of some of
these stories embedded in it.
In this part too.
Uh Hm.
Go through a similar unfolding
from and Ganja to this in Ganja.
Uh,
we will be following this development
in the episodes that we will be dealing
with during the rest of the semester,
some of which other culminating
episodes in the entire book,
not only, uh, the second part,
what the tire get haughty.
Uh, so, but that was first
turn our attention today,
uh, to uh, uh,
to critics whose essays you are
reading this week in the case book.
And this is, this is
sort of the, uh, the, uh,
the highlight or the high point
I should say, of the casebook,
these two essays by our back and Spitzer.
Now we already saw, uh,
our box main thesis,
we Macy's his famous book. And, uh,
that that thesis is about the
Christian mixture of the sublime,
uh, and uh, the low style
in the New Testament. Uh,
and how this led to the emergence and
development of realism and eventually to
the novel and to a book like the Quixote.
This mixture of the sublime and the law
style was a break away from the strict
separation between high and low style.
In the classical tradition,
which our back, uh, derives, uh,
this idea from Saint Augustine
and the church fathers,
the patristic tradition,
our back labels settling more immediately.
I put it on the board or humble
sermo better humble discourse.
This Christian response to the classical
division of styles derived that
division of styles derived from Aristotle
and from Roman rhetorical theory.
This mixture of the transcendent and the
low style was exemplified by Christ's
passion through which the drama of Man's
everyday life assumes the most profound
meaning. Life does not end in the
brief span of worldly existence.
Eternity is present in the
passion as a message of hope.
Our backs, uh, application of
these theory, uh, in the, uh,
to the Quixote leads him to the belief
that the Quixote is essentially a funny
book as you have read in the essay,
uh, the enchanted Boosie
Nair and interpretation,
uh,
for which our back was
excoriated by his Hispanics,
particularly Spanish
ones for whom Nikki Haut.
There was a very profound
at untrusting dental book,
although many we're motivated by a
nationalistic interpretation of Cervantes
whom they saw as the highest
example of Spanish genius.
And he's protagonist as the various
representative of the fatherland.
They will not entirely
wrong in their reactions.
What happened in Spain was that,
uh,
the key hot there was canonized,
meaning turning to a classic in the,
in the 18th century. Uh, and
then by the early 19th century,
during the romantic period,
uh, it was assaulted us, the,
the highest point of Spanish genius
and the highest representative of the
Spanish language in which the
spirit of Spanish. And this was,
uh, I was, uh, embedded and so
forth. And, uh, it became, uh,
this was a very nationalistic reading
of the Quixote that prevailed and still
prevails in some quarters. And, uh,
so the people who held this view of the
hotel of course were outraged by our box
reading of the Quixote as
essentially a funny book.
Uh, they were not entirely
wrong in their reactions. Um,
he should be very clear to those of
you reading the Quixote that there is a
great deal that is very
deep and serious in it,
both about life in general
and about literature,
our backs analysis.
However,
it's very revealing of how the law style,
particularly in St John,
all the low class characters plays such
a crucial role in the farcical episodes
in the chaotic, besides we are not, uh,
familiar in the modern period anymore
with this separation of styles are high
and low style or anything like that. And
it very instructive to read our bag, uh,
who was steeped in that, uh,
uh, even when he goes astray,
in my view,
I was criticized by some Hispanics for
having included that essay in the case
book,
by the way.
Mostly because they had not been included.
Our backs problem is that he cannot
get out of his home, his scheme,
which equals equates theory
looseness with uh, only with tragedy.
Don Quixote can be serious
without being tragic. And in fact,
this is one of its most important
lessons and most innovative qualities.
One of the most innovative qualities of
the new literature that emerges in the
wake of the Kiata to
say that's an advantage.
It's not deal with the serious
issues of his time is pure nonsense.
Uh, as we have seen, uh,
do claim that the book is above all a
farce is also nonsense besides a novel's
worth should not be gauged by how
faithfully represents reality.
If such a thing can be gauged at all.
Our back is wrong when he says
that Don Quixote's it they fix,
has no contact with reality and
that it only causes confusion.
On the contrary,
he see fix served by contrast to
clarify many things around him.
But there are salvageable
parts of our bags, essays,
essay, which is why I included
it in, in, in the casebook.
Um, novel cough. On the other hand,
the great Russian novelist has
a horrible book on the Quixote,
which was a series of lectures that he
gave, uh, at Harvard and the, there,
the book is interesting only
because Nabokov wrote it,
but he says really outrageous things.
Like there is no reflection of this.
Pain of the ranches is
time in the Quixote.
Nabo cough was a great writer,
but not a great critic. Oviously
I think that the first salvageable
salvageable thing in our backs essay,
his,
uh,
his reaction against romantic criticism
and the tendency to over interpret
whatever that means. Ultimately, uh,
our back writes the finding his own
position, the following you have in, in,
in the case book page 58,
four centuries. He says,
especially since the romanticist
many things have been read into him.
He didn't Quixote which he interested
want this, which he hardly for boated,
let alone intended such transforming
undescended interpretation.
Interpretations are often fertile.
A book like Don Quixote dissociate itself
from its author's intention and lead a
life of its own. Don Quixote shows a
new face to every age which enjoys him.
Jet,
the historian whose task meaning himself,
whose task it is to define the place of
a given work in a historical continuity,
most endeavor insofar as that is possible
in so far as that is still possible to
attain a clear understanding of what
the book meant to its author and his
contemporaries and court.
Uh,
this is the dream of the philology.
And so the critics steeped in philology
that they can actually get back to the
meaning of the, of the, of the work in Eh,
in the period in which was writing and,
and, and to discern what
the author's intentions,
where we are not so sure anymore.
Peter Russell's book, Peter
Russell was an English, uh,
Hispanics of some note.
His book is called Don Quixote as a funny
book follows our back and it's among
those who styled themselves as the
hard school of Savantas criticism based
mostly in England and,
uh,
who's hardness is mostly of the
intellectual arteries in my view,
just because the advantage is contemporary
is found the book funny or just
because of what's Advantis
said about the comic.
It is impoverishing to see
the Quixote in this light,
particularly when the
comic is not defined.
If the comic arises as it does in the
quota from the toils of our mind out of
sorts with the modern world,
then it is a comic of the
highest form of seriousness.
Comedy can be very serious and profound
and it is in the Houthi contemporaries.
Often Ms. Reed works written,
uh, in their time, obviously,
and author's intentions are very,
very difficult to ascertain.
And I'll say a little bit more
about that later. Spitzer,
Leo Spitzer was another great critic
of the German philological school.
He to escape from Nazi Germany and
proceeded our back in the chair at the
University of eastern bull.
Uh,
Spitzer wound up at Johns Hopkins
University, not on Yale, alas,
like our back
Spitzer was known to be irascible and
belligerent in the defense of his points
of view and road vicious reviews of
the books with which he disagreed.
Uh, for example, Steven Gilman's
book on the Cell Astena,
uh, was shredded by Spitzer
in an angry, uh, review
pitcher was more thoroughly grounded in
philology and linguistics than our back.
He was a, a philologist
and a linguist and, uh,
uh, spoke, uh,
many modern languages and new practically
all the classical ones. He was a very,
very,
very learned man and very brilliant.
She picks her beliefs that one can get
at the core of a work of literature by
going from something
marginal on the periphery,
like a detail and pursuing and all the
way to its center that a detail Caniff
properly analyzed year. The
comprehensive interpretation of the work,
the geometric metaphors,
periphery circle center are a beaten,
a bit naive here.
We use metaphors in writing theory
and engraving criticism and his,
uh, are a bit naive when
we think about them. Uh,
we learned to look for
metaphors in criticism in,
through the work of the
great deconstruction is Paul
the man who was a professor
here at Yale. So the geometric
metaphors are a bit naive,
uh,
as is spitzers emphases on discovering
the personality of the author or his
worldview. He's Weltanschauung
to use the German word.
He wants to get into the
psychology of the author.
These are approximations
that Michelle Foodco,
I think I mentioned him.
He's a French philosopher.
[inaudible]
who's most famous book is
liberal elite shows in English.
The translator as the order of things.
And the first three chapters,
I don't Hispanic things, one on Velasquez
Las Meninas, one of the grantees.
And the very first the beginning is
on board. Here's the Argentine writer.
Um, these are approximations and Michel
Foucault would argue that one limits the
possible meanings of a work by reducing
it to the alleged intention of its
author. If you say these
were the author's intentions,
you create kind of a fence
around a, uh, work on, uh,
uh, there can be no meanings, uh, beyond
what you assume those intentions, uh,
to be.
Uh,
but I believe that what
Spitzer is trying to find is,
is the servant was what
I call this advantage.
We should him is a point of confluence
between form and content that makes for a
coherent overarching meaning.
Since language is after all,
the primary material of a literary work,
I believe has pictures.
Work is a good lesson to critics who
would leap too hasty interpretations
without a detailed knowledge of the text.
Now that language is the,
is the primary material with
literary work might seem obvious,
but it is a very,
uh,
complicated a statement to make because
one could say that paint is the,
is the, uh, primary material of painting.
And that doesn't get you very far in
the case of, of, of, of language. It,
I think that it,
that it does not a far a spritzer would,
uh,
would believe,
but I think that it does in the
case of the, of the Quixote,
she pitched her, accomplishes his task
by meticulous work on Pollino Mattia.
But if you have this
words in your essay swamp,
I'm not going to have to put
them on, on, on the board. Uh,
I know that there are jawbreakers Paulino,
Manisha,
multiple names and polio, etymology,
multiple origins of words,
meaning multiplicity of ne of names and
multiplicity of word origins that are
present in this scenes that he analyzes
Spitzer equates the multiplicity
implicit in these
and the words to the
perspective as inherent in the
interplay of varied views in
the novel by various characters,
various characters,
and various different point of view.
And this is reflected in the, in the,
in the multiplicity of ideologies
and the multiplicity of names, uh,
uh,
given two characters and two things.
The differences of opinion among the
characters is evinced through the,
uh,
through the use of language.
The key term in the novel
is the Portmanteau Word
Sanctuary uses to mediate in
the dispute about the barbers basing
the Buffy yellow or the basing helmet in
English,
but which he attempts to
convey the conflicting points
of view about the object.
According to Webster, a
Portmanteau word and, uh,
James Joyce was famous for making them up,
uh,
is a word that he's a combination of
two other words, inform and meaning,
like the word Smug,
which is a combination of smoke and fog.
I bet you didn't know that.
Smoke and fog give you smog
and that is a Portmanteau word.
Uh, Joyce use uses it uses them. Uh,
um,
in funny ways,
a passenger in,
in Joyce is the
pass anchor, which in
France, French means not yet.
Of course a passenger is a bass core
because he hasn't gotten there yet.
And this is the kind of
thing that Joyce does. Um,
so that's a Portmanteau word and
embassy Gilmore basing helmet,
his apartment to work.
And you remember that Spitzer
mixed quite a bit of that,
uh,
much spacer but Spitzer ru's behind it,
mostly multiplicity that is [inaudible]
the creator of this whole artistic
machine.
He stands over all the games of
authorship and all of the ironies that is,
you can, you can, uh, you
can think of it, uh, uh,
Serantes and then all of the pulling
of Asia and all the bullying,
the margin of that,
but they are contained in
this figure of Cervantes.
The author who is the,
who is the author of all the ironies
and all of this against Cervantes.
Spitzer argues is no relativist
when it comes to morals.
We saw this already and
perspective is in an IRA,
an irony are inherent
in a Christian position,
which is humble by definition,
meaning I don't know enough,
I will never know enough to
behind Cervantes the creator.
There is God whom
Cervantes never denies so,
so they will be gone above Cervantes.
Spitzer provides a convincing historical
scheme during the Middle Ages.
There is a correspondence
between word and things,
names and characters. And this is, uh,
so in the readings of scripture
in the renaissance,
there is a word world,
a world of words,
to use my own portmanteau
word at world of words,
when connecting or leading to the next
by my autonomy and a world book world
made up of books like Alonzo
[inaudible] was a result,
becomes don Quixote.
But inhabiting that book world was a
world of books in the Baroque that is a
phantasmagoria of words that are like
dreams and reveal the deceit of the world,
including that of language here
in this world of the same gun.
You know, it's where we find instead of
on this particularly the Bantus have 16,
15. So, uh,
I put these things on the board because
I liked you to have clear ideas.
So Middle Ages,
renaissance and Baroque correspondence,
word things, words, the words,
and then words who are
the seat full, uh, and uh,
uh,
purveyors of [inaudible] and then
leading to death and gardening.
Now
I am very interested because,
uh,
I think it is useful for us as readers
and US students of literature in the
Cervantes according to
our backend Spitzer.
Uh,
to me the most interesting part of our
box essay is ultimately when he tries to
define this Advantium
low set of Valentino,
which can be compared with spitzers
effort to come to a similar overall view.
Your theoreticians and critics can
say that there is no such thing as
[inaudible]. Uh, yet there is,
there is a, you know, w w if you
have read the Quixote and you know,
literary history, you know, what is,
what belongs to a sort of
disadvantage world, uh,
is a great writer,
creates a world of,
of his or her own is, is
a set of plots, ideas,
tropes,
uh,
that has some coherence and that can
be identified if you have read Proust.
Uh, you know what I mean? You
read one boosting sentence,
his long flowing sentences and you know,
immediately you're reading,
you read a symptoms by bore with
these refined irony and you know,
you're reading uh,
a border borders or you read years
later before the firing squad Colonel
Aureliano when Dee,
I was to remember that remote afternoon
when his grandfather took him to who sea
ice or I'm trying to, this is the
beginning of 100 years of solitude.
And you know,
now our buck in defining the
Sylvanian begins by giving up.
He says the peculiarly servanty and
cannot be described in words because by
giving up, but then he says, first of all,
it is something spontaneously sensory
if vigorous capacity for the vivid
visualization of very
different people in very,
very situations for the vivid realization
and expression of what thoughts into
their minds,
what emotional fill their hearts on,
what words come to their lips.
You have to remember that
these quotes from our bar, uh,
were originally written in German and
German prose is very complicated and it
shows in the translation
later he says,
and just a sensory is his capacity to run.
This is to think up or hit upon and a
new combinations of people and events.
He's, I think he's right when he says
something like that, he goes back, uh,
our back goes back to the idea of the
mat gentleman running into people.
Uh, and he says, what attracted
Cervantes was the possibility,
uh,
this formula offered for multifariousness
and effects of perspective.
The mixture of the fancy food and
everyday elements in the subject is
malleability elasticity,
adaptability quote.
He finally proclaims the following.
This Advantium is an attitude and
attitude towards the world and hence also
toward the subject matter of his art
in which bravery and equanimity play a
major part together with a delight he
takes in the multifariousness of his
sensory play.
There is in him a certain southern here,
meaning southern European, not
folk, Marion's south, you know,
uh,
there is an incidence,
southern reticence and pride.
This prevents him from taking the
play very seriously. He looks at it,
he shapes it.
He finds a diverting.
It is also intended to afford the
reader refined intellectual diversity.
On quote, he goes back over this. He says,
the theme of the mad country gentleman
who undertakes to revive night errand
tree gay Cervantes and opportunity to
present the world as play in that spirit
of multiple perspective,
non judging and even non
questioning neutrality,
which is a brave form of wisdom.
There's something I think also,
uh,
quite perceptive there.
That is the advantage is like
a puppet master like a master,
uh, in, in, in,
in the episode Europe about the re,
uh,
and he presents all of these many
different characters who, uh,
in action and sort of stands
back without passing judgment.
Now Spitzer on the other hand,
uh,
uh, concludes the following.
These beans are in our novel.
Things are represented not for
why they are in themselves,
but only us.
Things spoken about or thought about.
And this involves breaking the narrative
presentation into two points of view.
There can be no certainty about
the own broken reality of events.
The only unquestionable true on which
the reader may depend is the will of the
artists who chose to break
up a multivariant Vaillant
reality into different
perspectives.
In other words,
perspectivism suggests the existence
of an archimedean principle.
Something on which the whole thing rests,
uh,
outside the plot and archimedean
principle outside the plot.
He goes on and the are, Kennedy's must
be sort of Anthony himself unquote.
And one more quote and we may see instead
of Andis two fold treatment of the
problem of nicknames.
Balino Mattia another example of
this baroque attitude. What is true?
What is a dream this time toward language,
the language itself is not human language.
Also a Vanitas Tattoo.
Tattooing vanity of vanities.
What I was saying about the,
the Baroque languages,
a phantasmagoria,
this is the end of,
of uh,
Spitzer syntheses is his conclusion
after this very thorough and brilliant
analysis of, uh, of the
novel. This is my view, uh,
I have been expressing in our rhetoric,
uh,
this is my beautiful view both
on our, uh, on our backend.
Spitzer in the
glorification of the author.
Spitzer does not take into
account Servantez errors.
He's famous oversights,
which we speak over floored creator,
not God.
Like in any sense,
hence pushing the whole issue of point
of view to the edge of the abbess of Matt
[inaudible].
I'm sorry,
of the abyss of madness
since the final authority is,
is, is flawed. Um, moreover,
Cervantes placed so much with the
author's lack of authority that one has
finally to take him at face value and
agree that not even he has authority.
Uh,
the final authority of the book that
we read and I think this he would have
agreed with,
uh,
and we have seen it in many in
our readings of many passages.
The same is true for our back.
My answer as you will see in my
essays is he ness cross idleness.
Remember that he needs is a figure of
the author and the figure of the modern
author. He has blown his book.
He wants to make money from it.
He's from the lower classes and he's
cross eyed and this reveals that there is
perspective is in from within an
assumed single self. That is that this,
this, this figure of the author here, uh,
cannot be in possession of the
truth because being cross eyed,
I don't know if I can
make him enough cross.
I'd hear his view of reality is flawed
and conflictive conflictive
because there are two eyes,
not a single point of view. And, and,
and this author figure being cross eyed
makes literally that he has that he's
two ice means two different visions.
We will talk about that when we
talk about the puppet play, uh,
that he needs the a Monte
puts on here in part two.
Um, so, uh,
the author is multiple within himself,
his eyes,
a work independently of
each other as it were.
He is congenitally incapable of
providing a single point of view.
Now we turn to the assigned episodes,
uh,
in the Quixote as we turn
to this episode's. Uh,
let me remind you that I will be looking
into how much each resembles an episode
in part one to what extent these episodes
are we writings of others that have
already taken place in the first book.
Also,
we will see that running thread
through these episodes is doubling the
appearance of doubles, uh, of Don
Quixote, of reflections of Oakley, Hopi.
Uh, the first is the episode
that is called in Jarvis,
uh, the episode of the night
of the looking glasses,
which makes it very awkward for me to say
because of course this is 18th century
England English and the English
say looking gloss for a mirror.
And uh, so, uh,
I say night of the looking glass is just
to be consistent with the translation
that you're reading this time around,
but it's in Spanish color yellow.
It looks at speckles night of the mirrors.
Now this episode brings to mind that
have the fight of Don Quixote with the
Basque in part one because
you do have an actual dual,
the most significant episode.
Uh,
the most significant aspect of this
episode is that in it, Don Quixote meets,
meets his mirror image image
and the feeds that mirror image.
Carrasco has decided that the only way
to subject Don Quixote is to meet him at
his own level.
But mostly what he's doing is reenacting
one in the way that donkey hope they
reenacted. Oh, really? I'm still
reenact the romances of chivalry.
Don't hot.
They will find a copy of himself
model after his own mat inventions.
A copy that is rich in details.
Notice that don't see now here is gassing.
They are they one Dalia Dalia means
and the Lucia land of vandals.
The vandals were one of the
Germanic tribes, but uh,
invaded the peninsula,
uh,
after the collapse or with the
collapse of the Roman Empire.
Carrasco Carrasco get up as at night
errand is quite something he has outdone
Gnocchi Haldane and here is a quote
from page five 54 Loki Hartej viewed his
antagonist and found he had his helmet
on and the beaver down down so that he
could not see his face,
but he observe him to be as strong made
man and not very tall over his armor.
He wore it kind of circuit
certitude or loose coat.
Seemingly have the finest gold be
sprinkled with sundry little moons of
resplendent looking glass,
which made the most gun and splendid
show a great number of green,
yellow and white feathers. Waved
about his helmet on. Quote,
this translation or the translation
struggles a bit with the lunas.
The word used in uh,
four mirror in the original mou,
Jazz Luna's their risk.
This is a horse
which contains that word, uh, um,
a most important suggestion
in the passage La Luna,
they lists backhoe is the
reflecting part of the mirror,
but lunar means moon
of course,
and moon leads to lunacy
do madness.
Sandstone is the night of the moons.
The night of lunacy denied of madness,
which is quite appropriate because in
trying to cure Doki hold this madness,
he's acting like a madman,
like a lunatic. The moon,
of course, he's also the
celestial body of reflected light,
but excellence the same as the
night of the looking glasses.
Sound song in this getup is
a reflection of don Quixote.
Quixote came close enough to some song.
He will be able to see himself
reflected on the little
as in the episode of
the Parliament of death.
Don Quixote has met in mirror
image of his madness here.
It's more than just a reflection that
is reflected in the in the night of the
most was acting like came and he's also
reflected in his armor being reflected
back from those little mirrors on his uh,
on his costume.
So you can see
sent Joe has also met his double in domain
CCL whose fault knows is a prodigious
example of the grotesque,
which is such a prevalent
quality in part two.
I quote scarcely had the clearness of
the day given opportunity to see and
distinguish objects when the first thing
that presented itself to Sanchez eyes.
What this choir of the woods knows,
which was so large,
that in almost over cha overshadowed
his whole body in a word.
It is said to have been of an excessive
size hawked in the middle and full of
warts and carbuncles of the color of
mulberry and hanging two fingers breath
below his mouth,
the size,
the color of the carbon
carbuncles and the cooker.
This so disfigured his face,
that sanctuary at site,
they're off being unto tremble hand and
foot like a child in a fit and resolved
within himself to take 200 cuffs before
he's color should awaken to encounter
that hub gobbling. I
mean, he says he was, he,
he may have thought that he'd had to fight
this fellow us there two matches with
Friday. He saying after seeing
that knows I would never,
never fight these monster.
Notice the exaggerated dimensions
and other hideousness of the nose,
which together with this being artificial
and new features of part to Muddy
Torres was naturally ugly and though
her physical deformities were extreme,
they were at least her own and not likely
to inspire fear so much as repulsion,
but here centuries moved to dread,
which will happen often.
Impart to fear is one of the emotions
that we encounter once and again in part
two and you can begin
charting them from now on.
Domestus yards. Nose is connected
to the aesthetics of the Baroque,
who's emblematic figure is the monster.
The figure made up of
disparate conflicting elements
like the nose and contrived
to cause admiration.
The monster is made to be shown.
And uh,
and uh, this quality is embedded in
the very etymology of the word monster.
Monster had him in Latin.
If Don Quixote has met him the
night of the looking glasses,
an image of his madness in Seattle central
has met an image of his foolishness
domain is like a carnival
figure of the fool.
And his costume is reminiscent of
those of the actors in the wild.
One of the parliament of death.
His name is [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible]
domain of course is, is, is,
is, is a form of Tomas, Tomas,
okay.
But Seattle at the time
meant a kind of trout.
So to maybe in the past,
his name means means I ate drought.
If you stopped back and think of it,
there are many names that mean something
and you don't catch onto it until you
think about it.
But this is scholars have come up.
I didn't define that
Tomasa, chairman, I trout.
Uh,
now the fact that that
domain is an image of, of,
of Sanchez is foolishness.
Foolishness is so much.
So because domain is Sanchez neighbor,
please eat
with whom you this courses some things
proper to squires and who's gluttony and
other habits.
He shares the dialogue about the
contingency of meaning in language.
A centering on ie whole there
Buta or on is hilarious,
but he speaks of a very
modern conception of language.
As spitter mentioned somewhere in this
essay that is meaning is contingent in
language. It is not fixed. It's shifting.
And this is consistent with
the view of the Middle Ages,
renaissance and Baroque and the Baroque.
This blue shiftiness of
languages emphasize. Uh, so
okay,
in the dialogue of the squires,
there is also a critique of the opera
class as a frequent topic in part two that
you might also chart as you read it.
They particularly central do not
accept the colts of Chinnery.
That leads that lead to such a oh fights.
Uh,
central seems to be saying that it
is the opera classes that start wars.
So very deep critique.
This is part of the political element,
uh,
of these second book of the 1615 Quixote.
Uh,
but also fits in with the semantics
of the disingenuous because,
uh,
the accoutrements of the opera classes,
they're luxuries are part of the seats
that are own done by the same guy.
No.
As you will see as you move through the
upper classes in the next few episodes.
Now, what is the significance
of all this doubling?
Okay, hold them. It's double
sanctions. Dobo I think that at the,
at the deepest level,
it means that the characters have met
themselves and struggle each within
himself to find meaning and identity or
identity within meaning or a form of,
of, of Weiss. Uh, self recognition,
troubled self recognition.
This is tied to the issue of self reflect
society that we have been discussing
since the beginning.
If the renaissance mind with
the mind of the renaissance,
if I may use an abstraction,
Sally's forth in search of the real world,
which it tries to interpret control and
use the baroque mind in that Sally in
forth fines mostly itself,
it finds its own inner workings.
This,
I equate to the God,
don't your sweet Gogi Ergo soon I
think therefore I am what you see.
Ultimate truth that the car
can find the card 1596, 1650,
roughly contemporary a little
later then of one. Yes.
But it's, it is itself, it
is a self recognizable jet.
This figure in this images it need a
further and further thought and reflection
with the, with the emphasis on
reflection on, on uh, like a mirror.
It is appropriate then for these
reasons that the characters should meet
distorted images of their own selves
or twisted reflections of themselves in
their adventures.
So Carrasco has falling into his own
trap while Don Quixote on have an almost
literally out of body experience seeing
themselves outside of themselves and
seeing themselves,
how they would look to others.
This is particularly
troubling to I think central,
but also to look the haughty who as the
novel progresses we'll find more such,
uh,
instances where a reflections
of this guy and uh,
undermine his, uh, his quest.
So, so we move on to the
episode of the Lions, uh,
which is reminiscent of that of
the galley slaves. In part one,
the lions,
like the prisoners are prisoners
and they belonged to the king.
They're are also under the
supervision of the crown.
Finding lions in the middle of
Casteel is not a common occurrence,
so their appearance is another instance
of the real conspiring to add to don
Quixote's madness by presenting him with
beings and objects that are out of the
ordinary,
like the players in the cart,
lions or object of a mule
of objects of amusement,
they'd been taken to court so they
can be viewed by the people. Uh,
amusement and display.
They are fit for heroic action and Don
Quixote does act with great courage only
to be marked by the lion,
but not only arts peacefully,
but turns his hind quarters to the night.
Ultimate insult theories him is no longer
possible under these circumstances.
It is a very cruel episode
for donkey haughty,
but together with the fight with
the night of the looking glasses,
these are two victories for Gnocchi,
Quixote,
which together with the knowledge that
is now in a book are to his deluded sense
of importance and of accomplishments.
The characters around him conspired
to increase this dilution,
but the lions are real and could have
killed him. Quixote and the others.
Jorge Luis Borges from I have
quoted so many times in this course.
The Great Argentine writers
says that, uh, uh, uh,
courage is the one characteristic that
is a constant from first from book one to
book two,
the courage of Don Quixote.
And then he's also the constant from
alone Sukarno to Don Quixote and back to
Alonzo Kiano at the end of the book.
And so we come to the gentleman in green,
the gentleman in the green writing coat,
uh,
in Don Diego de Miranda don't help
healthy meats and other double,
but an inverted one like a mirror image.
Don't [inaudible] appears to
read the Dolly go donkey hot.
They would have been had he
not read romances of chivalry
turn mad and chosen to
attempt to revive the age of Chimichurri.
He is like the night of the looking
glasses and other distorted reflection of
[inaudible]. The one I repeat
that he could have been don't.
Leo is the image of what the French
in the period called the [inaudible].
He is reasonably well off,
reads devotional books,
humps and lives, an honest, peaceful
life at home. Don't be haughty.
Mocks him slightly in the episode of
the Lions when Don Diego prudently runs
away and again as he takes his
leave telling him that the,
that he's not looking out,
they says he's not given to
leisure leisure like Don Diego.
Diego is a kind of pre dra character.
Uh,
but he has a son who wants to be a
port lowering. So they meet under,
we have once again the
postprandial conversation and
one more time to discussion
center centers in the relative
merits of arms and letters.
This is a repetition of that episode,
but now you know what?
Appointed house not in a dilapidated in
and Don Quixote's has interlocutors who
are or his intellectual level Lorens who
is quite a good poet who reminds us of
resource resource to more on Gardenia
but does not take action as they did.
Though Quixote reveals that he
knows a great deal about poetry,
but the outcome of the exchange is
that Cheever re surpasses poetry.
That arms are superior,
who letters.
This whole section seems to be,
uh,
in homage of Gfsi Lasso,
the La Vega,
the great Spanish board
of the 16th century,
whose name I've mentioned many times
and who has become by this time,
the model of Port Kertscher
and soldier Garcia Lasso,
uh, who lived in the first
half of the 16th century, uh,
died while attempting to scale the
wall of the castle during a battle.
Uh, in Charles if his army,
they dropped a rock on him.
He only lived 36 years,
but his poetry
changed the course of
poetry in Spanish forever.
Cervantes was quite devoted to him.
The discussion turns to the issue of
if report can be made or if he's born.
And,
uh,
this again gives another example of
Don Quixote's extensive readings,
uh, other than, uh, rather than
merely a books of chivalry.
Uh, this is the library beyond
the library that was burnt by the,
by the priest and the barber and,
and the women that don't get hurt.
This house.
And then we come to a, uh, uh,
the last episode I'll be discussing today
and which is a transition episode to
go mattress wedding.
This is the episode of the swordsman,
the two sportsman who begin to argue
about who's better. One is very,
very strong and the other one
is an expert, a scientist of,
of, of, of fencing at this time, uh,
since the advent of firearms and all of
that fencing had become a sport and a
not only a sport or a science,
I were books written about
trying to understand, uh,
fencing in geometric mathematical terms
and surrounded like to poke fun at this.
However,
it is the scientific stories man who uh,
who makes a fool out of the other one who
is so strong that at the end when he's
very angry,
he takes his sword and throws it so far
away that it takes a long time to get up
there and pick it up. The
point of this, uh, uh,
uh,
throw away episode it may seem is that uh,
it shows that art triumphs over nature,
that science triumphs
over strength on the,
the triumph of art over nature is a
baroque topic that appears once and again
throughout part two.
And we are going to be talking about
that in the next class when we talk about
commercials wedding in relation to a
painting by the Alaska is called the
spinners last.
Elon Elandra's.
But now we have to turn on to conclude
to our exemplary story,
the glass graduate,
which I hope that you, uh,
uh, that you have written.
We have gone over the 16,
13 exemplary stories book,
how Cervantes published it because
publishers became interested in his work
after the success of the 1605 Quixote.
Also,
once he realized that he couldn't use
the stories which he had a in the way he
used an in part one because he had been
so criticized and you have read about
the criticisms as they appear at
the beginning of part two. So, uh,
I said one test who prided himself on
being the first to ever write this kind of
Noel and the Spanish language collected
them in this wonderful book that would
have given serve anthesis uh,
a prominent place in the, uh,
in, in the Canon even if he had
not written the whole thing.
Now the glass graduate good.
He's one of the better known stories,
famous for the very strange kind of
madness that afflicts the protagonist.
He believes himself to be made of glass
and lives in constant fear of being
broken.
It is another example of Cervantes is
profound interest in the workings of the
human mind and in issues concerning
knowledge and the ability to arrive at the
truth.
Tomas,
he a very suggested
suggestive sort of paranoia.
It is an illness that has a [inaudible]
air to it in Kafka's the metamorphosis.
As you know, the protagonist,
uh, becomes a roach.
Tomas suffers mls that is expressed
through fear of bodily harm or physical
fragility.
It is a way of feeling different
than vulnerable that can be extended.
It's extended to a general human
condition, a form of alienation.
I think this is the main reason
why the story is so compelling.
The idea of this madness that you feel
yourself made of glass and therefore
vulnerable and you would, you tried to
establish a distance between you and and,
and others who might break you or have
or anything that was a tile falling off a
roof. My break you and
taking laborious, uh, uh,
uh, measures to protect, uh,
you're very vulnerable, uh, uh, a body.
Now the novel begins as if
it were to be a compressed,
kind of been doing for months.
That's a German word for word of,
of or novel of Education.
Bill doing education building from us.
But then it moves on to
encompass Tomasa's entire life.
It is not however,
a biography,
but it centers on two or
three periods of his life,
most particularly on the
one during his illness.
The plot is circular and a circularity
is expressed through Tomas.
Very last name. First.
He's called [inaudible].
Yeah.
His last name is [inaudible],
which means slice is a
slice or not quite a circle,
a fragment. It was fear,
but when he, at the end,
when he recovers from his illness and
is in full command of his faculties,
his last name becomes
Rueda, which means wheel.
So he has been completed.
We go back to Spitzer and
his bully. No Meisha. Um,
now during his illness,
he is known as the [inaudible],
which is the name of the story in Spanish,
which means the license should
delay at licentiate glass window.
They call him graduate glass
in the translation, but
media, music glass window,
a stained glass window or a glass
display case. So this is what his name,
his name's, uh, is again go back,
we have to go back to Spitzer and
names and things and so forth. Uh,
there is something passive about
Tomas except when he's ill,
but on the whole things happen to him.
He was found lying down under some trees
by the young gentleman who take him to
Salamanca using their,
uh,
in the their servant for eight years,
but also acquires an education
showing a remarkable intelligence.
Though he's only, this is only
reported not dramatized until he's ill.
He is always in a second plane.
I said, we're as a soldier,
he moves around trying to soak up as
much experience and culture as possible.
Tomas is then administer a poison by the
spurned woman spraying the woman who is
no quarterly damn soul border,
notorious whore who
falls in love with him.
The poison queens preserve [inaudible]
that she gives him is redolent with
sexual connotations as in
Latin, in the, in, in, in,
in the classics. The memory
Yoda in the original Latin, uh,
was associated,
uh,
by way of resemblance
with female sexual organs.
This is how she lures him into eating it,
but there is no hint of what makes him
attractive to her other than perhaps is
famous. A brilliant scholar. It seems like
a whim that she falls in love with him.
She disappears and that is as far as
the erotic thing goes in the story,
it disappears when ill Tabasco is placed
and remarkable intelligence and wit
being not only insightful in his
observations but making these with pumps,
sharp witticisms and
clever circumlocutions.
He's a regular like and
he's like an oracle and he's
consulted as such by people.
There is a correlation between his illness
and his insightfulness which seems to
hinge on transparency since he
believes himself to be made of glass.
And if you go to page one 13,
you will find a quote in which,
uh, he says, uh, he, he,
he challenges them to ask him questions
that he will be able to answer for uh,
uh, but because he was a man
of glass rather than flesh,
I'm quoting for since glass was
a finance delegate substance,
his mind to function more
quickly and efficiently in that,
in a conventional body, uh,
which was made of a denser,
an earthly or stuff.
I mean his body would be denser and
glass is transparent and so forth.
This is a page one 13.
Uh,
in other words,
Tomas,
mine makes transparent the world around
him just as his body is presumably
transparent. Transparency
gives him access to the truth.
But he's also said to be highly
educated and intelligent.
So He's into insightful.
Does once he's ill,
it's like an increase of these
qualities or is it disconnected from it?
It is not clear if,
if it was the poison or the precarious
condition in which he believes to be,
that sharpens his wit.
He is like the black man in
the traditional story who
can tell the emperor that
he is naked because he has
nothing to loose. Uh, because,
uh, Tomas because with illness
has become a sort of of freak.
He has no reputation to protect.
Uh,
and so he pierces through all social
convention and through hypocrisy and lies
and tells the truth. Uh, he also, uh,
in, uh, outlining the
various virtues and defects,
uh,
of each of a profession or trade
is following a traditional formula,
a set,
a set piece that became a skid in the
theater to someone who tells well amongst
do this and cobblers do that. And
that, that is behind this story.
Now they,
the black graduate has much in common
with the Quixote and seems to dramatize
the common debate,
uh,
in that book between arms and letters
because it's both a soldier and his, uh,
an a student, a brilliant student,
and Salamanca last unit. Uh,
but whereas don Quixote's mainly and
reader of literature of Romances of
children, we, above all,
Tomas is a legal scholar whose
mission is reaching the truth.
His quest is more intellectual than
literary. So in that sense, uh,
he is not quite like Don Quixote.
He is different,
more philosophical if one could say,
the ending seems to suggest as
it is throughout the holder,
the preeminence of arms over letters
when he has to escape from Salamanca.
Uh,
and it goes back to Flanders and has a
career in the army and ends his life,
uh, owner ugly. Now will,
we will be looking at other exemplary
stories in the near future and you will be
able to experience the variety of
plots and narrative experiments that,
uh, the book contains. And that I
think is the reason for its being.
For this story's being
colleague exemplary.
They are a collection of
samples or examples of, uh,
plots and stories.